[Musik]
[Gelächter]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
herzlich willkommen in der hochschule
für philosophie ignatius von loyola und
martin luther 2 vorkämpfer für den
christlichen glauben ein reformator und
1 gegen reformator ein baske und ein
sachse an diesem ort in einer hochschule
der jesuiten wollen wir heute abend über
martin luther diskutieren ja hier auf
dem podium das sind zunächst herr
professor gunther wenz ist vormals
ordinarius an der
evangelisch-theologischen fakultät der
ludwig-maximilians-universität münchen
heute leiter der wolfhart pannenberg
forschungsstelle an der hochschule für
philosophie daneben professor doktor
volker gerhardt von der humboldt
universität zu berlin
dort hatte wenn ich mich nicht täusche
seit 25 jahren ein lehrstuhl für
praktische philosophie rechts und
sozialphilosophie und mir gegenüber
sitzt herr professor dr georg suns
inhaber des eugen biser
stiftungslehrstuhls für religions- und
subjekt philosophie ebenfalls hier an
der hochschule für philosophie ein
halbes jahr nach dem berühmten
thesenanschlag in wittenberg am 31
oktober 1517 diskutierte martin luther
auf dem generalkapitel seines eigenen
ordens der dominikaner 40 weitere thesen
und die dreizehnte dieser heidelberger
thesen lautet das freie willens vermögen
nach dem sündenfall ist ein bloßer name
ein leeres wort also seit der
vertreibung aus dem paradies ist der
mensch nicht mehr frei sondern
gewissermaßen gefangener der sünde und
aus der sünde kann er sich nicht mit
eigener kraft lösen sondern ist dafür
auf die gnade gottes angewiesen
drei jahre später der papst hatte diese
these luthers inzwischen verurteilt
insistiert luther ein weiteres mal
das freie willens vermögen heißt es ist
ein hirngespinst oder einnahme ohne
inhalt erasmus von rotterdam
der roman ist er ist luther nie
persönlich begegnet er hat anfänglich
mit den positionen des reformators
sympathisiert aber je weiter sich luther
von der kirche des papstes abwandte
desto skeptischer wurde erasmus unter
dem drängen einiger freunde und
möglicherweise auch mehrere bischöfe und
nach langem zögern entschließt sich
erasmus auf die thesen martin luthers zu
reagieren
er tut das in einer streitschrift das
lateinische original ist etwa 100 seiten
lang und er verteidigt in dieser
streitschrift gegen luther den freien
willen
die reaktion martin luthers ließ nicht
lange auf sich warten
luther reagiert auf 200 seiten wieder
auf latein mit einer schrift die dann in
der deutschen übersetzung den titel
trägt dass der freie wille nicht sein
antwort doktor martin luthers an erasmus
von rotterdam mutter war von dem
diskussionsbeitrag des baslers nicht
gerade begeistert gewesen
events was wollte luther können sie uns
in kurzen zügen schildern wo die absicht
des reformators lag ein christenmensch
ist ein freier herr alle dinge und
niemandem untertan ein christenmensch
ist ein dienstbarer knecht alle dinge
und jedermann untertan
mit diesen beiden sätzen beginnt heute
seine schrift von der freiheit eines
christenmenschen die liebe dathe
christiane aus dem jahr 1520 die maxime
lautet domini so muss wir sind herren
weil wir des herren sind
und das ist in der tat die kurzfassung
der zentrale these der reformation nur
weil wir ihm glauben
von der sorge um unsere ewige seelenheil
gründlich entledigt sind sind wir frei
zur dankbare tat und fürsorgliche liebe
ich will es in einem satz zusammenfassen
kann so lieben um abitur gratia de wohl
lieber tat christiana gegen den er was
jetzt freien willen für die gnade gottes
und für die freiheit des
christenmenschen
warum habe ich gezögert lieberum albion
ohne weiteres mit freien willen zu
übersetzen
weil diese wendung klärungsbedürftig ist
genauso wie luthers gegen diese dieselbe
bio dass der freie wille nicht sein in
welcher hinsicht ist er nichts
das ist uns ein augenblick ein paar
terminologischen fragen erwägen wollen
heißt auf etwas aus zu sein
auch der trieb ist auf etwas aus aber
triebhaft und nicht willentlich der
wille unterscheidet sich also vom trieb
und wenn ich mit lottes these natur
kausale der minister assoziiere dann
sitze ich von vornherein einem
fehlurteil auf der wille es von trieb zu
unterscheiden und das tut auch luther
der wille es aber auch von willkür zu
unterscheiden
wille es mit bewusstsein mit verstand zu
assoziieren der wille sucht also nach
gründen und ein begründer der wille
etwas anderes als willkür
wir dürfen also den willkür begriff
nicht mit dem willen begriff
unmittelbar gleichsetzen es ist eine
nicht nur die effizienz form des willens
sondern eine verkehrte form des willens
wenn der wille willkürlich nichts
anderes ist als bloßes belieben
also ein wille der seinen namen verdient
ist auf gründe aus und nur laute die
frage worin gründet eigentlich der wille
selbst oder wurden gründe dass ich das
will
in irgend etwas in der welt nein sagt
luther als denkbare alternative kommt
deshalb nur dass ich selbst in frage ist
der grund meines willens und der grund
meine willensfreiheit das unmittelbar
selbstbestimmtes selbst das länder ab ja
darin in dem akt unmittelbares
selbstbestimmung des menschen entdeckt
die grundverkehrt haid des willens und
die grundverkehrt hyde der freiheit
es ist ein akt der freiheit aber ein akt
grundverkehrt freiheit und jetzt erst
immer an dem punkt an dem die
auseinandersetzung mit erasmus anfängt
wird er leugnet nicht dass wir wählen
können
aber wählen können wir nur im blick auf
ähnliche sachverhalte setzen wir uns im
blick auf den fundierten den grund von
selbst und welt also im blick auf gott
in einwahl verhältnis und insistieren
auf die möglichkeit zwischen gott und
nicht gott gleich eine alternative zu
wählen
dann ist das schon ein akt des
verkehrten will's nicht als ob mutter
jeden wahl willen bestreiten würde aber
zu wählen gibt es nur etwas im hinblick
auf endliche handlungsalternative
im blick auf gott als den grund meines
selbst und alle welt gibt es nichts zu
wählen
ja im blick auf gott auf wahlfreiheit zu
insistieren wäre schon eine grund
verkehrung des willens ja ich will es
zugespitzt sorgen wäre schon sünde und
zwar nicht nur irgendeine atoll sünde
sondern nur das urteil zur folge dass
bekam originale die uhr sünde
schlechthin
deshalb kann es sich mit der us-mission
lösung beim besten willen nicht
befreundet
auch er was muss sagt 99,9 prozent die
gnade gottes aber irgendetwas muss noch
hinzu treten in einem aktiven sinne
damit nicht ein dreh des senator ischer
determinismus stadt hat dem stellt sich
luther kompromisslos entgegen
jede vorstellung gott ist freiheit mit
der menschlichen freiheit in einem
additiven verhältnis zur bestimmte
länder ab linde nicht nur ab sondern
sieht er als die grundverkehrt haid
alles menschlichen willens und alle
menschlichen freiheit an
rg hat
hat rasmus luther hat luther erasmus
verstanden was wollte erasmus gut dass
sie so einsetzen und dann muss ich jetzt
nicht gleich auf das reagieren was ja
wenn's gerade gesagt hat was wollte er
wir müssen uns daran erinnern luther ist
er nun bekannt würde ich mal annehmen
wir haben jetzt ein jahr luther jubiläum
gehabt und einiges über ihn erfahren
aber wir wissen wenig über erasmus und
da ist es mir nicht ausreichend nur
einfach humanist sagen er ist vor allem
derjenige der schon zu beginn des 16
jahrhunderts eine neue literarische
gattung dass ihr der ire der ideen
kritik der ironischen verzeihen sie der
ironischen kritik an der gesellschaft
entwickelt hat im lob der torheit und
hat dadurch einen bildungs gedanken auf
den weg gebracht der für ihn und sein
wirken und dann auch für dieses wirken
im rahmen der reformation
außerordentlich wichtig war
erasmus ist aus meiner sicht einer der
gründer der europäischen neuzeitlichen
politischen philosophie er hat im jahre
1500 und 15 eine kristen erziehung auf
den wunsch von kaiser maximilian
geschrieben und für die beiden söhnen
ferdinand und karl die dann große
bedeutende fürsten in europa gerade
während der reformation waren hat er
versucht prinzipien eine republikanische
verfassung zu entwickeln die ohne
freiheit gar nicht denkbar ist eine
freiheit sich an die gesetze zu halten
gerechtigkeit zu üben und etwa mit dem
damit sie eine vorstellung von der
wirklich außerordentlich man im
außerordentlichen mut des erasmus haben
auch dazu führt dass er diese beiden
künftigen fürsten davon überzeugen will
dass wenn sie den eindruck haben nicht
für ihr amt wirklich ausgerüstet und
geeignet zu sein
zurücktreten müssen und dann auch
bürgerliche an ihre stelle rücken lassen
müssen
oder aber dass die gerechtigkeit sich
natürlich orientieren muss an an
allgemeinen gut und an den allgemeinen
vorschriften aber man bei jeder
durchsetzung der gerechtigkeit daran
denken muss das schwache gibt und diese
schwach diese schwachen immer diejenigen
sein werden die zu kurz kommen und
insofern das ist ein ganz moderner
gedanke der im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
erst von john rawls aufgekommen ist ist
das etwas ganz innovatives und ich
bedauere sehr dass auch die politischen
philosophie des philosophen das in der
gegenwart nicht genügend bedenken ich
könnte jetzt noch einige andere dinge
aufhören aber es ist ganz wichtig der
erasmus vor allen dingen auch durch
seine philologischen arbeiten eine
grundlage geschaffen hat für die
übersetzung des neuen testaments durch
luther und immer wieder auch durch
eigene schriften großes interesse daran
gezeigt hat dass die kirche sich
reformiert und nachdem sie erst einmal
so gespalten war sich ende der 20er
jahre dann in den 30er jahren noch
einmal ganz stark eingesetzt hat für die
vereinigung der kirche in einem
gemeinsamen glauben ich glaube das ist
sehr wichtig um zu sehen dass es erasmus
darum geht zunächst einmal die freiheit
des bürgers deutlich zu machen dass eben
ein staatliches zusammenleben nicht
anders möglich ist als dadurch dass der
einzelne einsicht hat dass er gebildet
ist und von dieser einsicht er sich
entscheidet und insofern könnte ich das
aufnehmen was gerade events gesagt hat
es geht ihm natürlich wesentlich um die
entscheidung im hinblick auf weltliche
dinge und dass der bürger frei ist und
dass der mensch daraufhin frei ist und
wenn sie sagen 99,9 prozent könnte man
ihm zu geben beziehen sich auf jene
endlichen weltlichen dinge dann würde
ich sagen wesentlich für erasmus war
dass er die freiheit forderte für jeden
menschen im hinblick auf politische
und moralische dinge dass es ganz
entscheidend aus meiner sicht allerdings
auch und das wäre vielleicht das 0,1
prozent wenn es auch darum was man denn
eigentlich glaubt und insofern ist der
glaube selbst auch ein gegenstand der
freiheit und ich will das jetzt nicht
ausführen aber wir wissen heute im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wie
wichtig ist es gerade auch im hinblick
auf die erklärung des glaubens noch eine
freiheit zu unterstellen und deswegen
kann man nicht von einer prämisse
sprechen die schon einmal im glauben
gesetzt sein muss ehe man dann darüber
entscheiden ob der mensch frei ist oder
nicht er wenn es dann wieder hole ich
die frage einfach nochmal hat luther
erasmus überhaupt verstanden
nun er hat glaube ich verstanden was das
zentrale problem ihre kontroverse war es
geht es streit ja nicht nur um dieses
oder jenes und es geht es streit auch
nicht darum inwieweit und ob es
überhaupt so etwas wie politische
freiheit gibt das ist von luther nicht
in abrede gestellt worden dass in der
äußeren sphäre und stars freiheit statt
hat und das in der äußeren sphäre der
freiheit jedem bürger ein entsprechendes
freiheitsrecht so zu erkennen ist
das wird man unschwer mit luther in
verbindung bringen können
die zwei regiment lehre ist so angelegt
dass jedweder zwang in glaubensfragen
auszuschließen ist
ich will nicht sagen dass leute selbst
und die prinzipien der religionsfreiheit
die gewissensfreiheit und nicht
identifikation von staat und kirche in
entsprechender weise zur geltung
gebracht hatte realisiert hat aber die
ansätze in diese richtung die sind bei
lotte zweifellos zu finden
aber das ist nicht das zentrum des
streits an der streit geht darum ob der
menschliche wille oder genauer gesagt
ob die menschliche wahlfreiheit ob das
liebe zum abitur etwas vermag
in bezug auf die ewigen dinge und das
bejaht er was muss und das verneint
lotte mit welchen argumenten weil der
mensch in bezug auf seinen willen
hinsichtlich des grundes von selbst und
wer nämlich hinsichtlich gott sich nicht
in das verhältnis des wählenden setzen
darf tut dies dann hatte das gottes
verhältnis schon von grund auf verkehrt
nur dagegen polemisiert leute aber das
ist in der tat erzählt wahl frage der
theologie und auf dies sollten wir uns
auch im folgenden unserer diskussion
konzentrieren erklärt würden sie mit
luther damit gehen also ich verstehe
sehr gut warum luther vor dem
hintergrund seiner gnaden theologie es
ausschließen will dass der mensch sich
mit seiner freiheit in mögliche
entscheidungen gottes einmischt hier
gibt es eine ganz klare trennung der
sphären und das ist in der tat wie ich
finde ein wesentliches anliegen der
reformation dass die sphäre gottes nicht
durch menschliche handlung nicht durch
institutionelle versuche in irgendeiner
weise beeinflusst wird so dass der
mensch dann offen kann er habe durch
gute werke oder aber durch anderes durch
spenden oder aber die schmerzen lesen
lassen und so weiter und so weiter
irgendetwas für sein seelenheil getan
also in diesem punkt denke ich ist die
position luthers nicht nur sehr klar
sondern auch im hinblick auf die
eigenständigkeit der göttlichen stellung
der souveränität eines gottes etwas das
man gar nicht bestreiten kann
aber ich bin der meinung es dass es zu
diesem
heftigen streit niemals gekommen wäre
wenn es tatsächlich nur um dieses letzte
moment gegangen wäre es ist deswegen
habe ich gerade auch diesen ganz kurzen
vorspann gemacht zu erasmus starken
politischen engagement und seiner großen
weltgeschichtlichen bedeutung wie ich
meine im hinblick auf das was er uns
auch im hinblick auf den bildungs
gedanken in erziehungs gesamten der ja
dann eben auch etwa von melanchthon auch
von luther fortgesetzt worden ist dass
er hier sein wesentliches interesse
hatte und eben befürchten musste dass
die position luthers eine ist die
letztlich zu einer entmündigung des
christen als eines bürgers führt das hat
den streit zu meine ich eskaliert und
hier ist denke ich auch die
außerordentliche bedeutung dieses
streits weswegen wir diskutieren so
meine ich nicht über eine theologische
spekulation über das was etwa die all
wirksamkeit gottes bedeutet und
inwiefern er sowie die kausalität
sozusagen bis zum letzten punkt der welt
auch alles bestimmt so dass überhaupt
kein ort für die freiheit liebe sondern
es geht ihnen um die reale freiheit des
menschen auch und das ist der punkt auch
im hinblick auf den glauben selbst und
ich würde sagen der eigentliche
streitpunkt ist der ob wir erst den weg
zu gott und zu seiner gnade gefunden
haben müssen um dann aus dieser position
heraus als frei die dinge die ja vor
allen der welt zu entscheiden oder ob
wir eine freiheit annehmen die uns auch
dazu bringt zum glauben selbst zu diesem
oder einem anderen oder überhaupt zu
einem glauben ja oder nein zu sagen
das ist ein ganz entscheidender punkt
muss ich auch jetzt nicht erläutern
und dafür gibt es so meine ich einen
wesentlichen ansatzpunkt bereits zum
sechzehnten jahrhundert und das führt
mich dazu im theologischer hinsicht zu
sagen wenn es darum geht zu sagen
haupt die absolutheit gottes als solche
anzuerkennen da kann man luther keinen
vorwurf machen das ist richtig aber wir
sind dabei über etwas zu streiten was
unsere stellung in der welt angeht und
hier darf kein zweifel sein dass wir
gerade auch weil die biologen und die
physiker und viele andere diesen zweifel
heute ja sehen dass es diese freiheit
als eine reale wahlmöglichkeit geben
muss events sind wie real frei zu
glauben oder sind wir uns frei zunächst
will ich sagen dass er ganze reihe was
mission motive selbstverständlich auch
in der reformatorisches christen um
integrierbar sind es wäre in der tat
viele das verhältnis zwischen
information und humanismus als er ab
sagte alternative zu begreifen man muss
man philipp melanchthon erinnern dass
diese vorstellung abwegig ist also
vieles von dem er hat was sie gesagt
haben ist unschwer analytische tradition
zu integrieren nicht aber dass sie den
eigentlichen streitpunkt als nur
apostrophieren wenn es nur das nennen
da geht es um alles und lothar dankte
erasmus den stil so zusammen bei den
hörnern gepackt zu haben
denn wenn mein verhältnis zu gott wie
minimal auch immer im sinne eines
lithium eine wahlfreiheit bestimmt ist
dann ist es im sinne luthers viel
bestimmt dann handelt sich so mehr
verkehrte bestimmung und an der
heftigkeit dieser auseinandersetzung
darf man glaube nichts ab märkten wenn
man überhaupt über unsere thema sprechen
will
wir können über alles mögliche sprechen
aber wenn wir über die
auseinandersetzung sprechen wollen die
um 1525 stadt hatte hier die libido und
dort dieselbe abitur dann muss man schon
über die frage sprechen
ob es angemessen ist
im hinblick auf gott ein lieberum abc um
ihn anschlag zu bringen
das verneint lotta und insofern hat
justus jonas dieselbe aktion richtig
übersetzt dass der freie wille nichts
sei im hinblick auf gott und insofern
ich beantwortete frage herr sams wäre es
auch viel bestimmung des glaubens den
glauben primär als entschiedenheit zu
bestimmen
glauben heißt vertrauen und vielleicht
ist die beste übersetzung im deutschen
sich verlassen den grund seines selbst
in nichts in der welt aber auch nicht
unmittelbar in sich selbst sondern in
gott zu suchen und zu finden
lg hat kann ich mir aussuchen auf wen
ich mich verlassen
was sollten sie besser nicht
insbesondere sie nicht ersetzen aber ich
glaube dass wir doch bei den fragen um
die es geht jetzt nicht den versuch
machen
in einzelne interpretations folgen zu
gehen ich interpretiere erasmus gerade
auch in seinem versuch der mich selber
nicht wirklich zufrieden stellt in
seinem versuch auch vier verschiedene
bedeutung von gnade aufzunehmen um
möglichst nah doch an ein gnaden
verständnis heranzukommen
ob er damit luther gerecht wird in einem
engeren theologischen sinn das vermag
ich auch als nicht so locker nicht zu
sagen man sieht sein bemühen man sieht
seinen versuch luther auch in diesem
punkt gerecht zu werden aber es bleibt
eben ganz entscheidend und da würde ich
ihnen widersprechen wenn es ganz
entscheidend ob man zu einer solchen
glaubens bestimmung erst kommt unter den
bedingungen des vertrauens unter den
bedingungen ist eines bereits für einen
selbst erwiesenen sich verlassens auf
oder ob man
ich sage es jetzt mal ganz aktuell als
moslem als jude als katholischer oder
protestantischer kritik christ sich in
irgendeiner weise überhaupt erst vor die
frage gestellt ob man nun glaubt oder
nicht und ich halte das für eine ganz
entscheidende frage und am erasmus ist
für mich dermaßen interessant die
tatsache dass er durch und durch an der
antike orientiert ist und wie jemand der
sich so stark mit der antike beschäftigt
alle damaligen gedanken überspringen
kann und in mancher hinsicht als der
modernste erscheinen kann im hinblick
etwa auf seine politische philosophie
das ist für mich außerordentlich wichtig
und deswegen würde ich sagen hier an
diesem punkt hat er in seinem
widerspruch gegenüber luther etwas sehr
wichtiges aufgenommen auch im verhältnis
auf unser auf unsere beziehung zu gott
auch in der beziehung zu gott geht es
bevor wir das vertrauen gefunden haben
bevor der weg beschritten worden ist
schon um eine möglichkeit zu sagen ich
glaube aber oder zu sagen ich weiß es
nicht ob ich wirklich ja sagen kann und
ob ich glaube diese entscheidung ist
nach erasmus immer noch durch den
freiheitsbegriff gedeckt sie haben beide
auf unterschiedliche weise angespielt
auf die unterscheidung die sich bei
erasmus aber auch bei luther findet
zwischen der freiheit in weltlichen der
willkür freiheit in weltlichen
angelegenheiten der politik einerseits
und der entscheidung zu glauben
andererseits aber gibt es zwei typen von
freiheit lässt sich das überhaupt
trennen hands falls sich ihre frage
richtig verstanden habe will ich
verneinen
auch die bürgerliche freiheit verdient
ihren namen nur dann wenn sie von
willkür unterschieden ist handle so dass
die maxime
eines handelndes grundlage einer
allgemeinen gesetzgebung werden könne
handle verallgemeinerungsfähig das ist
der begriff der freiheit auch die
bürgerlichen freiheit den begriff der
freiheit in bürgerliche hinsicht mit ihm
der willkür gleichzusetzen wäre absurd
und auch eine fehlende freiheit im bezug
auf ähnliche sachverhalte wird nach
gründen ausschau halten müssen
also von daher ist begriff des willens
und der freiheit in hohem maße
differenzierungs bedürftig worum es
jetzt geht und worum es auch dem glauben
geht ist der unbedingte grund der
freiheit und diesen unbedingten grund
der freiheit finde ich nicht in der welt
und was liegt näher als ihn in mir
selbst zu suchen und in der weise von
selbst begründung figuren von figuren
unmittelbare selbstbestimmung zum zuge
zu bringen
und dagegen richtet sich lotte und auch
darin können so hohes maß an modernität
entdecken was versteht erasmus unter
freiheit herr gerhardt es ist die
freiheit im hinblick und da kann ich die
formulierung aufnehme im hinblick auf
das was man selbst eingesehen hat auf
gründe nur diese gründe können wir nicht
vorab schon zensieren und eben darauf
beziehen dass wir zwei ganz
unterschiedliche gründe haben solche die
sich auf gott beziehen oder eben durch
die göttliche gnade legitimiert sind
oder das was wir als einen zureichenden
grund ansehen und diese gründe weil wir
in der welt sind auch in der welt
handeln können auch gerade vor
existenziellen fragen eben solche gründe
seien die uns im leben begegnen also
muss sich der grund auch darauf beziehen
wir haben verschiedene modelle von
freiheit schon aus der antike einmal
unter den bedingungen der stoischen
wie eine konzeption wo die freiheit
insgesamt mit einer durchgängigen
bestimmung von allem vereinbar sein soll
das kann man zeigen dass dies eben
schwer möglich ist dass ist unter den
bedingungen des causa liz muss der
moderne auch wieder aufgetaucht darauf
berufen sich auch die physiker listen
und die hälfe theologen darüber muss man
nicht lange sprechen wenn es so wäre
dass die freiheit sich tatsächlich als
eine lücke irgendwo im system zeigen
müsste dann lässt sie sich nicht
nachweisen aber wir haben schon in der
antike die vorstellung von freiheit als
etwas das von sich selbst aus sich
bewegt und es ist luke reetz der
deutlich macht dass dies das modell des
lebendigen ist das sich aus sich selbst
heraus plötzlich trägt und dann seine
eigene bestimmung findet und eine andere
wichtige ist dass ich gegenüber dem
willen eines anderen freiheit zeige
indem ich sage das mache ich nicht dass
ich bin nicht bieten also das sind die
beiden formen und ich denke das erasmus
um auf ihre frage zu antworten geben auf
diese beiden momente von freiheit einmal
das sich aus sich heraus bewegen als
eines lebendigen wesens und zum anderen
eben in der beziehung zu meinesgleichen
wo ich mir eben wo ich meine freiheit
zeige dadurch dass ich mir nicht alles
sagen lassen kann und dafür ist lothar
nun so meine ich ein wirklich
exzellentes beispiel hat geschichte
gemacht er hat keine in einer weise
beeindruckt wie niemand anderes in dem
er eben auf dem reichstag nein gesagt
hat hier stehe ich und kann nicht anders
das hat heine stärker beeindruckt als
alle großen beweise sagte ausdrücklich
von erasmus und schöne schriften von
melanchthon die alle richtig sind luther
ist aufgetreten und hat die freiheit
durch sein handeln bewiesen und das ist
ein handeln sie würden sagen war ihm nur
möglich aus dem glauben richtig würde
ich auch vermuten dass das so ist aber
es war ein handeln in der welt aus
seiner einsicht heraus
aus die er als derjenige hatte der vor
diesem jungen kaiser stand der ebenfalls
und der großen problem druck stand naja
wenns und her gehört vielen dank für
diese eindrucksvolle erneuerung dieses
streits den wir jetzt sehr deutlich vor
augen haben und im nächsten schritt
wollen wir jetzt mal aus verschiedenen
perspektiven diesen freiheits streit
zwischen erasmus und zwischen luther
beleuchten und zwar aus drei
systematischen perspektiven um es dann
in die gegenwart zu holen diesen
freiheits streit eine erste perspektive
wird jetzt sein das problem der
neurowissenschaften
wie verhalten sich luther und erasmus zu
deren erkenntnissen was die freiheit
anbelangt der zweite perspektive wird
das problem der vorsehung sein
das ist ein riesenproblem für lothar und
erasmus wie verhalten die sich dazu und
eine dritte perspektive die wir jetzt
aktualisieren und auf diese
streitgespräch werfen wollen ist das
problem der menschlichen freiheit
erfahrung also diesen subjektiven
charakter der freiheit wie sieht es da
bei luther und bei erasmus aus und wir
haben jetzt hier meldungen im publikum
ich hab zuerst eine meldung von herrn dr
dettinger der eine frage an die beiden
diskutanten hat zum thema
neurowissenschaften und dieser
freiheitsstrafe bitte ja vielen dank
zunächst für diese bisher sehr spannende
diskussion innerhalb der damaligen zeit
geschichte in den vergangenen jahren
haben nun ja die neurowissenschaften
diese debatte um willensfreiheit
erweitert beziehungsweise bereichert
dafür waren sicher ein wichtiger impuls
die sogenannten liebert experimente die
benjamin libet 1979 durchgeführt hat das
hat zu diskussionen geführt in den
frühen 80er jahren aber bis heute wird
darüber diskutiert
es ging dabei um messungen von
hirnströmen in bezug auf das
bewusstwerden von willens entscheidungen
das ergebnis war bevor menschen bewusst
wird dass sie zum beispiel ihren arm
heben
lässt sich bereits ein entsprechendes
eine entsprechende nervenaktivität im
gehirn feststellen
etwa eine halbe sekunde bevor das
bewusstsein dieser willensentscheidung
bewusst wird
auf dieser grundlage gibt es oder gab es
und bis heute gibt es sie provozierende
äußerungen von neurobiologen wie gerhard
roth oder wolf singer die den freien
willen als mythos bezeichnen als die
sagen die entthronung des menschen muss
gefordert werden da der angebliche freie
wille nichts anderes als ein soziales
oder psychologisches konstrukt darstellt
die verschaltungen im gehirn geht voraus
und nur als vollzugsmeldung oder als
quittung belegt kann das bezeichnet
werden was uns als bewusste entscheidung
bewusst wird
aktuell habe ich wahrgenommen dass
gerhard roth sich auch zum sich geäußert
hat dass ich ist die oberfläche auf das
aus dem unbewussten willens ja
entscheidungs vorstellungen wünsche sich
sich zeigen und essig hat das gefühl
diese wünsche sich zu eigen zu machen
und letztlich ist es allerdings eine
eine lüge eine illusion
meine frage wäre luther nun eventuell
dankbar für diese scheinbare
unterstützung der neurowissenschaften in
bezug auf die zurückweisung eines freien
willens vermögens ich habe wahrgenommen
ergänzt das in bezug auf die freiheit
die in irdischen dingen auf endliche
dinge bezogen ist sie angedeutet haben
dass auch hier keine freiheit im sinne
dieser selbst bewegung wie herr gerhard
von luke rät ausgehendes aufgezeigt hat
dass luther auch in bezug auf die
wahlfreiheit bezüglich endlicher dinge
auch von einer freiheit spricht die im
letzten gottes
die wirksamkeit gottes wirken im
hintergrund hat insofern wären die
neurowissenschaften die auch sagen es
gibt keine absolute willensfreiheit
während die eine unterstützung für
luther ließe sich das zusammen sehen
da kann ich sie beruhigen
von einer unterstützung kann in der
hinsicht überhaupt nicht die rede sein
ich habe deutlich zu machen versucht
dass lottes kritik am libitum mit
irgendwelchen formen natur kausalen
determinismus schlechterdings nichts zu
tun hat es ist schon die assoziation
dass beides was miteinander zu tun haben
könnte eigentlich lassen es mir das
jetzt mal etwas zugespitzt sorgen
dienste unkenntnis dieser schrift
das zweite was die position selbst
anbelangt das ist ja unbestreitbar dass
diese diskussion ohne mehr oder minder
steige gehirntätigkeit nicht zustande
käme ist etwas ganz was anderes zu
fragen ob deshalb diese diskussion ein
bloßes eben phänomen nur physische
prozesses sei er tut es
ich frage was bedeutet die hier
entwickelte these für die theorie selbst
der alte trick der theorie dass theorien
als sich selbst angewendet werden müssen
und ich würde diesen
neurowissenschaftlern mal im fehlen
ihre theorie auf die
neurowissenschaftlichen ergebnisse
selbst anzuwenden
dann geraten sie in gewisse
schwierigkeiten in gewisse apulien und
erfurt ist und der letztes sie stehen
vom richter und sagen ja ich wäre auch
ein besserer mensch wenn ich andere
gewesen wäre oder andere geworden wäre
es wird keinen richter beeindrucken
darum noch einmal dass unsere geistige
mentale fähigkeit ohne substrat neuro
physischer art oder wie es immer
bestimmen wollen
gar nicht denkbar ist es ist klar dass
unsere geistes tätigkeit ohne unseren
leib nicht funktioniert das bild als
eigentlich keine großen gedanken aufwand
um dieses fest zu stehen
aber ob deshalb das was man geist seele
oder was weiß ich wie nennen möchte ob
das zum bloßen phänomen herabzusetzen
ist das nun mal ganz andere geschichte
ich würde sagen thesen dieser art die
mit einer naturnahen determiniert haid
alle geistes tätigkeit regnen laufen auf
einen eklatanten selbst widerspruch
hinaus herr gerhard würde es erasmus
genauso sehen
das würde erasmus sagen zu diesem
problem der neurowissenschaftlichen kann
das abkürzen ich glaube er kannte das ja
nicht und konnte sich wahrscheinlich
diesen unsinn gar nicht vorstellen aber
wenn er das auf diese weise vorgetragen
bekommen hätte hätte er genauso reagiert
wie events ist hier mal eine einigung
wenigstens erreicht in dieser frage das
ist ja schon mal zwischen luther und
erasmus über die neurowissenschaften
dass man die aus deren perspektive
abweisen müsste diese erkenntnisse
bezüglich der freiheit die
infragestellung der freiheit da wäre
sicherlich ein gemeinsamer punkt
vielleicht zu finden
jetzt haben wir noch eine weitere
perspektive die wir auf diesen freiheits
streit werfen wollen und die zweite
perspektive ist jetzt das problem der
vorsehung und zwar möchte ich hier herrn
frisch um seinen kommentar bitten zu
dieser thematik
ja ich habe zwei fragen zu diesem thema
eine populäre und eine eher akademische
zuerst die populäre frage
diese enge anbindung der freiheits frage
an
die vorsehung wir diesen vorsitz begriff
scheint ja nun gerade das ganz besonders
gestrige unmoderne an diesem streit zu
sein
ist dem so oder lässt sich dem thema
doch irgendeine gegenwarts relevanz
abgewinnen auch über philosophisch
theologische fach debatten hinaus
das war die erste frage die zweite frage
wäre folgende es gibt einen wunderbaren
text des italienischen renaissance
humanisten lorenzo walla indem er die
frage der willensfreiheit in dialogform
eben auch unter dem aspekt der vorsehung
frage oder dieses vorgehens problems
behandelt und dieser dialog nimmt zwei
interessante wendung die erste sendung
besteht zunächst darin spitzwegs in der
erkenntnis dass sich das man sich die
sache mit der vorsehung nicht so
vorstellen darf als würden menschliche
handlung gewissermaßen direkt von der
göttlichen vorsehung verursacht also
angewandt auf dieses judas beispiel das
auch schon weil er bringt nicht weil
gott vorher wusste dass judas jesus
verraten wird hat judas jesus verraten
sondern umgekehrt war judas jesus
verraten hat hat gott vorhergesehen dass
judas jesus verraten hat das ist
allerdings nur die erste sendung des
dialogs im folgenden zeigt sich dann
nämlich dass auch wenn die vorhersehung
eben nicht als direkte ursache ein
geschehens und insbesondere menschlichen
handlungen zu verstehen ist sich vor
sicherungen doch und allwissenheit doch
nicht ohne die annahme der absoluten
vorher bestimmtheit allen
innerweltlichen geschehens denken lässt
also in dem sinne wäre dann
die predigt im rheder die pre
determination des menschlichen willens
zwar keine direkte wirkung der
göttlichen vorsehung wohl aber eine
implikation derselben und mir scheint
dass man diese beiden wendungen des
dialogs in gewisser weise erasmus und
luther zuordnen kann und die frage wäre
dann einfach welche wendung des
gedankens sie für theoretisch
attraktiver halten vielleicht mit herrn
winds beginnen
zu dieser frage nach der vorsehung ist
ja auch für luther ein riesen thema
gewesen
ich versuche die nach meinem dafürhalten
sehr abstrakte frage zu konkretisieren
und nutzt die konkretisierung zugleich
die wahlfreiheit nochmal etwas zu
problematisieren
die schiere faktizität unserer existenz
stand nie zu unserer disposition stand
nie zur disposition und des willens
keiner der vier versammelten wurde je
gefragt ob auf die welt kommen will oder
nicht
dieses faktum entzieht sich ihrer
wahlfreiheit grundlegend und jetzt
könnten sie sagen ja wenn das so ist
dann ist ja meine freiheit von anfang an
grundlos ohne fundament das tun sie aber
nicht
vernünftigerweise nun können sagen meine
freiheit besteht immerhin dahin dies zu
tun was gott verhüten möge nämlich
meinem dasein ein ende zu bereiten
aber auch damit können es die schilde
faktizität ihres hier gewesen sein es
nicht mehr beseitigen
sie haben also schon in ihrer existenz
faktum zu dem sie sich verhalten müssen
ohne dass dieses verhalten dasjenige der
wahlfreiheit sein kann
wie verhält sich der glaube dazu
er glaubt dass der grund seines daseins
unbedingt ist unbeschadet alle
bedingungen die mitspielen bis hin zu
den eltern das der grund des daseins
unbedingt es und der religiöse ausdruck
dessen ist das der grund in gott zu
suchen und zu finden ist dass ich
vorgesehen bin und dass das was mich und
meine lebensgeschichte betrifft nicht
aufgeht in einem sammelsurium von
zufällen sondern dass es in gott
bestimmte art der notwendigkeit findet
nicht diejenige die in der natur zu
finden wäre zwischen natur und gott ist
sorgsam zu unterscheiden
wohl aber eine notwendigkeit die die
bloße kontingents meines daseins mit
sinn erfüllt so würde ich den fusions
begriff konkret wenden
und wenn es den forschungs begriff dann
mit dem gedanken der allwissenheit
gottes verbinden
dann müssen es gerade im christlichen
sinne sagen der allwissende gott weiß
auch was es heißt nicht allwissend zu
sein der allwissende gott weiß auch was
es heißt im hinblick auf grund grün auf
grundsätzliche fakten meines daseins
ungewiss zu sein
all das müsste es dann mit dem begriff
der den allwissenheit gottes und der
vorsehung gottes also ziehen sonst
kommen nur zur abstrakten vorstellung
eines
das objekt deshalb wie auch immer
geartete weise alles vorher weiß und
dann entsteht die notwendigkeit ist es
vorher wissen mit anderen kausalitäten
nur mühsam zum ausgleich zu bringen
aber der ansatz der frage ist zu
abstrakt und deshalb muss die frage nach
der vorsehung gottes konkretisiert
werden
dann ist bei einer entsprechenden
fassung zuzuführen gehabt was tun sie
aus verlagen also hinter das ist ganz
kurz ich kann nur sagen für mich ist es
schon zu abstrakt gott überhaupt solche
attribute zu geben wie etwa
allwissenheit wir wissen gar nichts
darüber und das entspricht auch unserer
verehrung des göttlichen darüber gar
nichts aus zu sagen wir haben zeichen
wir können diese zeichen deuten aber wir
können in keiner weise durch solche
begriffe das was wir unter gott
verstehen festlegen und ich gehe davon
aus dass aus dem ursprung der lehre vom
göttlichen bei luther es keine
möglichkeit gibt den ernsthafter weise
in irgendeiner weise etwas festzulegen
was dann kommt und wenn das ist ist dass
unsere interpretation und bei erasmus
ist der von mir eingangs betonte akzent
auf dem worauf es bei uns ankommt und
vor allen dingen das bewusstsein davon
dass wenn wir diese verantwortung
verfehlen so viel falsch läuft gerade
eben in seiner darstellung auch in der
frieden schrift das alles immer aus dem
besten willen heraus dann doch wieder
zum krieg führt das scheint mir ist der
beste grund davon auszugehen dass wir
versuchen unsere sache so gut wie
möglich zu machen soweit wir gute gründe
sehen und eine vorhersehung von unserem
wissen haben aber das nicht in
irgendeiner weise auf gott zu
projizieren
vielen dank sie sprechen von der eigenen
perspektive von uns
das bringt mich zum letzten zur letzten
perspektive die wir auf diesen freiheits
streit werfen wollen und zwar die
menschliche freiheit erfahrung also wie
kann man sich das vorstellen frei zu
sein determiniert zu sein aus der sicht
von luther aus der sicht erasmus und so
haben wir jetzt eine weitere frage von
frau professor dr
welche treki die jetzt diese letzte
perspektive auf diesen freiheits streit
werfen wird um diesen streit auch wieder
in die gegenwart in die gegenwärtige
diskussion zu bringen
ja ich möchte gern der kürze der zeit
geschuldet vor allen dingen aus der
perspektive des modernen handlungs
bewusstsein nach der anschlussfähigkeit
von luthers position für den modernen
menschen also uns als zeitgenossen
fragen
wir haben heute nachmittag in der
diskussion die erstaunliche mich
überraschende these gehört dass luther
mit seiner position zur willensfreiheit
also mit dieser radikalen bestreitung
etwas spezifisch modernes habe und ich
kann das eigentlich gar nicht recht
verstehen weil ich den eindruck habe
dass der moderne mensch also so wie wir
ihn alle kennen
doch vor allen dingen durch das
selbstbewusstsein ausgezeichnet ist sich
als handelnder ernst zu nehmen und wir
haben vor und zurück dekliniert die
korrelation von freiheit und
verantwortung es ist uns ein vertrauter
gedanke dass wir für alle freiheiten und
für die freiheit die wir in anspruch
nehmen einen hohen preis zu zahlen haben
ich glaube dass moderne bewusstsein ist
auf diese korrelation konditioniert ich
frage mich ob umgekehrt die lutherstadt
paradoxie uns für unser handeln jegliche
verantwortung zu zu sprechen so dass wir
an allem was wir verbrochen oder unter
umständen sogar an allem das uns nicht
gänzlich gelingt schuld sind und dafür
den preis der verwerfung zu zahlen
hätten wir aber deswegen noch lange
nicht als korrelat für diese starke
verantwortlichkeit auch freiheit in an
auch nehmen dürfen ob der moderne mensch
sich diese paradoxie tatsächlich zumuten
lässt und ich denke das führt ja auch
abgesehen von dem problem dieser
inkonsistenz durchaus dann wenn man den
lutherischen kontext berücksichtigt in
eine tiefere paradoxie hinein ist die
gottesvorstellung die luther diesem
ganzen dieser ganzen radikalen position
zur bestreitung der willensfreiheit
unterlegt also die vorstellung eines
gottes der wie luther sagt allen rom für
sich beansprucht und keinen dem geschöpf
zugesteht einen gott der nicht gönnen
kann der also anders als augustinus in
seiner frühen schrift der libero abi
trio eben nicht als der gott angesehen
werden darf der den menschen den freien
willen als geschenk gemacht hat eine
position die erasmus wieder zu
aktualisieren sucht ist diese
gottesvorstellung für den modernen
zeitgenossen anschlussfähig ist die
gnaden theorie die luther vertritt der
zufolge man diesen gott aber auch nicht
im mindesten durch irgend etwas das man
selber vollbringen kann
in seinen entscheidungen modifizieren
könnte für das moderne handlungs und
freiheits bewusstsein anschlussfähig ich
habe den eindruck dass ja in diesen
zurückliegenden reformations jahr
gerade diese brisante debatte zwischen
erasmus und luther ganz kläglich
unterbelichtet worden ist ich habe eine
internet recherche veranstaltet der
zufolge es in diesem ganzen jahr das ja
vorbei ist bis heute elf vorkommnisse
der thematisierung der debatte zwischen
erasmus und luther gibt das ist bitter
wenig bei all dem was wir sonst alles
gehört und rezipiert haben und ich frage
mich ob das bei den verantwortlichen für
die organisation dieses jubiläumsjahres
darauf zurückzuführen ist dass sie
vielleicht die debatte selbst nicht
genügend würdigen oder kennen
oder ob es daran liegt im gegenteil dass
die debatte die debatte nur allzu gut
kennen und damit die befürchtung
verbinden müssen das moderne
christenmenschen das was luther da
vertreten hat wahrscheinlich nicht in
dem masse goutieren wie andere
unterhaltungsveranstaltungen oder
sonstige angebote in diesem reformations
jahr notiert worden sind vielen dank für
die frage gibt es gleich weiter an herrn
wenn es dass die thesen die leute
vertritt in hohem maße spärlich sind das
ist klar
und dass die lektüre solche schriften
nicht jedermanns sache ist ist auch klar
er ist ja mit augustin erwähnt tolle
läge ihm hin und ließ das sollte auch
die grundbotschaft diese veranstaltung
sein sich nicht dass zweiter hand zu
informieren
so nun mal die texte selbst zu lesen
dass es sich um texte des 16
jahrhunderts handelt ist klar und dass
diese texte des 16 jahrhunderts nicht
unmittelbar unseren geist wieder spielen
ist auch klar aber die beschäftigung mit
history und des systematischen
gesichtspunkten kann auch ein
produktives befremden hervorrufen und
dieses produktive befremden könnte dann
auch die frage schaffen was ist denn mit
dem begriff der modernen freiheit
eigentlich auf sich hat hat jetzt den
eindruck man wisse dies ich sage es ist
in hohem maße klärungsbedürftig und der
begriff der freiheit und willensfreiheit
ist differenzierungs bedürftig und es
wäre es hier pauschal jetzt zum schluss
die these vertreten zu bekommen oder
habe die freiheit des willens
frei weg verdammt oder in abrede gesteht
davon kann überhaupt nicht die rede sein
er hat in bestimmte hinsicht vom lieben
addition gesprochen hat im hinblick auf
ähnliche handlungsziele der wahlfreiheit
nicht nur nicht in abrede gestellt
sondern ausdrücklich anerkannt
seine grundthese abc dass derjenige der
weiß wovon die rede ist wenn von gott
die liebe ist das verhältnis des
menschen zu gott nicht im sinne des
lieben abitur also nicht im sinne einer
wahlfreiheit bestimmen kann
das ist die these die er gegen erasmus
vertrat und mit der diese muss man sich
auseinandersetzen
er hat vielleicht noch ein sie ziehen
sie es genauso
ich würde sagen da muss man eben auch
erasmus lesen und erasmus geht in seiner
bestreitung keineswegs so weit dass er
meint es müsse damit eben ein eingriff
in das was gottes wille ist vorgenommen
werden sondern es ist eine in bezug auf
das was der mensch in seiner einstellung
zu seinem leben und seinem handeln für
wichtig hat wofür ergründet hat und
wofür seine einsicht spricht und da ist
es meines erachtens wirklich wichtig zu
sehen dass in diesem punkt luther eine
ganz andere position hat als die die wir
heute haben würden wir über freiheit
sprechen und ich würde sagen wir müssen
auch eine andere position haben weil wir
etwa von der vielfalt der religionen
ausgehen müssen weil wir ganz andere
bedingungen der wahlfreiheit haben und
nicht von vornherein eine ganz bestimmte
form der entscheidung für einen glauben
vertrauen voraussetzen können und wenn
wir diese freiheit nicht zugestehen dann
wissen wir in der tat heute nicht ganz
unabhängig davon was im 16 jahrhundert
nicht wissen oder wissen was wir heute
nicht was ihr
der freiheit zu verstehen haben nur noch
einen satz ich halte das was die geiste
zeit oder der angebliche geiste zeit ist
für erläuterung bedürftige ich möchte
das wort von der zumutung trotzdem
nochmal aufgreifen das wurde in den raum
gestellt sowohl das menschenbild als
auch das gottesbild luthers sind eine
zumutung und ich würde sie beide jetzt
einfach mal fragen events gibt's
wenigstens irgendwas was luther uns
zumutet die frage überrascht mich jetzt
denn ich finde die schrift insgesamt
eine zumutung aber eine zumutung mit er
sich auseinanderzusetzen
in hohem maße lohnendes er gehört recht
hat lotte unter all seinen schriften nur
die beiden charismen und dieselbe abitur
für erhaltenswert erachtet das hatte
nicht unbedacht gesagt so nochmal meine
herzliche bitte lesen die beiden
charismen und lesens bei gelegenheit
auch dieser beziehung gehabt was mutet
der erasmus uns zu
das hat mich jetzt gefragt was mutet
luther und zudem ermutigt uns etwas zu
und ich meine dass diese zumutung auch
tatsächlich von uns ernst genommen
werden muss angesichts von situationen
in denen wir wenn sich etwa das
gesellschaftliche umfeld in einer von
uns nicht mehr beeinflussbaren umwelt
und umgebung verändert hat wie das zb
unter den totalitären regimes des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts der fall war
und den einzelnen nichts anderes übrig
blieb als eben entweder sich anzupassen
oder widerstand zu leisten da gibt es
seine unbedingtheit des freiheits
wunsches in einer ganz anderen weise die
jeder natürlich auch auf seinen gott
beziehen kann aber es ist eine
existentielle unbedingtheit und die
sollten wir verstehen und da ist denke
ich wirklich jemand
der uns etwas zumutet und diese zumutung
sollten wir gerade unter bedingungen
produktiv machen jederzeit auch heute
für uns wieder kommen können
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir sind am ende unserer diskussion
angelangt ich danke den beiden
gesprächspartner und herrn professor
doktor volker gerhardt ein professor
doktor gunther wenz von herzen
ich hoffe dass zumindest so viel klar
geworden ist freiheit ist bei weitem
mehr als ein leeres wort oder ein bloßer
titel wie luther mal sagte ich danke
allen anwesenden und wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend auf wieder schauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]